además de estar durante toda la guerra
usted ha viajado por el país cuéntenos
cómo ha cambiado a ucrania según su
visión
sí sí depende en realidad muchísimo de
la de la zona y vive en el oeste del
país yo diría que se ha continuado a
vivir con cierta normalidad aún en el
miedo de este miedo y esta atención y
también de algún bombardeo ocasional muy
distinta a la situación en el este del
país donde los combates siguen ustedes
lo mencionaban también hace poco ahí la
gente ha tenido que aprender a
sobrevivir con las sirenas con estos
cien días que han sido un sin parar
realmente de guerra de una guerra que
está continuando y también quería
mencionar el tema de las ciudades
ocupadas las ciudades ucranianas
como gerson de melitópol y la misma
marie paule ahí es una incógnita la
situación de los civiles tenemos pocas
informaciones y también hay que
mencionar que la perspectiva de cara al
futuro es que estas personas las
personas que aún quedan en estas
ciudades en un futuro estén viviendo
a unas zonas que serán parte de que
podrían ser parte de otro país por tanto
realmente la situación es muy distinta
según donde uno está en ucrania y en
este cubrimiento que historias son las
que más le han impactado
me han impactado muchísimas historias
que son difíciles de relatar en imágenes
como está cambiando la sociedad
ucraniana también el tema del
nacionalismo que será algo con lo que
ucrania tendrá que lidiar después de que
este conflicto se apague también me ha
impactado la calidez por ejemplo de las
de las personas en el este donde como
decía antes se siguen estos combates muy
intensos
de estas personas que viven literalmente
bajo las bombas también lo he visto en
otros conflictos en por ejemplo en siria
he visto estas hartazgo de la guerra en
cierto momento que llega también a las
personas que se tienen que enfrentar a
esta realidad de forma cotidiana que
quieren seguir viviendo y que por tanto
encuentran formas
sobrellevar estas situaciones todas
estas historias
son difíciles de relatar a veces pero
son parte de la realidad de ucrania de
este momento hartazgo por parte de la
ciudadanía pero cuál es la situación
para los periodistas que tanto riesgo
corren los reporteros
bueno es una guerra convencional con lo
cual el riesgo existe nosotros andamos
por ahí con nuestros chalecos nuestros
cascos pero por supuesto
al haber artillería si uno acaba en
medio de disparos
de esta magnitud del peligro
evidentemente es muy alto por supuesto
se intenta medir todo se intenta medir
las rutas por lo que uno pasa el momento
del día la situación en el terreno pero
el escenario los escenarios son muy
cambiantes todos los días hay novedades
la línea del frente se va moviendo
constantemente hay ciudades que pasan de
mano constantemente y de alguna forma se
refleja en el número de periodistas que
han fallecido hasta ahora que ya son más
de una veintena y como lo hemos
reportado en france24 ucrania sufre una
crisis de abastecimiento qué tan difícil
es conseguir los alimentos
es difícil conseguir
muchas cosas los alimentos pero también
las medicinas los ancianos por ejemplo
sufren mucho por esto porque algunos
tienen patologías previas y no es fácil
para ellos sobre todo estamos hablando
de la zona del este nuevamente es
difícil abastecerse de gasolina la
gasolina es esencial para el transporte
y por tanto de alguna forma influencia
todo lo demás realmente todo en lo que
significa
poder acceder a todo tipo de alimentos
de medicinas de de productos básicos
para la vida cotidiana y de nuevo aquí
como les decía antes los que están
sufriendo más son los que están en la
primera línea y por tanto las ciudades
más afectadas
del este y en particular de la zona del